a trump lawyer Alina Haba
is now making the new claim that Nancy
Pelosi orchestrated the January 6 2021
Trump riots at the U.S Capitol
how is that possible how is it possible
that that's what she did well here she
is Alina Haba explaining it herself
and there are two basic fundamental
important claims that underlie this idea
they've both been debunked and we're
going to get to them but understand that
they don't even know what to say anymore
and so now it's forget about Trump
didn't incite the riots Nancy Pelosi
orchestrated them don't need it get them
in place he was concerned himself he
said let's get extra uh military we will
give you people to come in and to make
sure that the capital is safe no no I
don't want it well now we see why Eric
we see why because it was orchestrated
because she said this is her moment this
is her moment no it's not your moment
okay so there's two claims there and
these are claims that they've repeated
many times the first claim is
Trump asked for 10 000 National Guard
troops which would have prevented the
riots that's claim one okay this is how
we actually figure stuff out okay the
first claim is Trump says I asked for
ten thousand troops they didn't give
them to me the second claim that's being
made is Nancy Pelosi
rejected the ten thousand troops coming
to Washington DC to prevent the rights
so two claims Trump requested Nancy
Pelosi rejected neither one of them is
true the first one is the Trump claim
okay
there is no evidence that Trump made
that request now
if you want to be endlessly uh skeptical
you can always say is it possible Trump
requested the troops and the request was
thrown in the trash in order for there
to be no evidence you can always do that
but the point here is
there is no evidence
uh written
Telecommunications
people on the other end of the request
saying yeah I got we got that request
from the Trump White House for the
National Guard troops PolitiFact has
explored this and has determined that it
is false they have found no such
evidence
the second claim is that Nancy Pelosi
rejected the troops Sean Hannity has
been saying it for a very long time and
so have others again there is no
evidence that Nancy Pelosi Chuck Schumer
or anyone else rejected the request for
the ten thousand or sometimes it's
twenty thousand troops that are
mentioned now of course if there's no
evidence that the request was ever made
there's no request to reject either and
that's another layer to this thing
that's important to mention I would love
it if Alina Haba made some of these
claims under oath
I don't think that's going to happen and
remember that Donald Trump's TV lawyers
and his court lawyers tend to be
different people we heard from Michael
Cohen about how that works and I don't
expect to actually see Alina have him
make any of these claims under oath but
every single one of these claims has
been soundly rejected and or there is
simply no evidence for it whatsoever one
way or the other because it doesn't
appear that such a request was ever made
they'll keep telling the LIE and we have
to keep reminding them there's just no
evidence you're just saying that you're
making that up
something in your home that you use
every day contributes to deforestation
and climate change and that's toilet
paper in the U.S alone over 30 million
trees each year are required to meet
toilet paper demands contributing to
deforestation soil erosion devastating
loss of biodiversity our sponsor real
paper makes sustainable toilet paper
that is 100 made from bamboo a bamboo
stock keeps growing it can be harvested
forever it means that the soil and the
ecosystem aren't disrupted no carbon
removing trees are cut down the paper
industry has a massive effect on
deforestation and climate change but you
alone using bamboo toilet paper can make
a positive impact because for the toilet
paper that just one American uses in
their lifetime hundreds of trees are
required put an end to that right now
with real paper the best part is this
stuff is really great it's just normal
Soft toilet paper real paper loves the
David Pacman show they're giving my
audience 30 off your first order and
free shipping when you go to
realpaper.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below